parce que le stade de france aurait été
mieux géré la réponse est oui bon est ce
que j'en ai une part de responsabilité
la réponse est oui je
m'excuse bien volontiers 3 5% c'est la
hausse générale des salaires décidée
pour les fonctionnaires le gouvernement
vient de l'annoncer sa entrera en
vigueur le 1er juillet un truc tout bête
par exemple qui qui scandalise dès qu'on
le dit donc je prends mon risque sur ces
news la loi à partir du moment où on se
dit que fondamentalement on doit
augmenter les salaires pour permettre
aux gens de s'en sortir par rapport à
l'inflation ya qu une seule condition il
faut travailler plus d'après des
semaines d'accalmie le coc vide va-t-il
gâcher les vacances d'été la septième
vague a bel et bien commencé et les
pharmacies tourner à nouveau à plein
régime est ce que vous demandez leur
tournée passe vaccinale je pense ou peut
imaginer qu'à partir de fin juillet
début août pour le passage des
frontières
il risque d'y avoir une demande de
nouveau de passes vaccinale la russie ne
peut ni ne doit gagner et donc
notre soutien à l'ukraine et nos
sanctions
contre la russie se maintiendront n'irai
pas jusqu'à l'obligation est en tout cas
je demande aux français de remettre le
masque oui effectivement dans les
transports
unibail violentes tornades a coûté la
vie hier à une personne et fait neuf
blessés a dit riggs et sur la côte c'est
le premier phénomène météorologique de
ce type à faire des victimes dans le
pays depuis près de trois décennies sur
décision du peuple une assemblée
profondément renouvelée s'installe
chacun ne pourra que se féliciter que la
sagesse du corps électoral et puis venir
composer la brutalité compenser
excusez-moi compenser la brutalité d'un
mode de scrutin qui a parfois donné le
sentiment amer à certains français de ne
pas être représenté
damien abad visé par une nouvelle
plainte pour tentative de viol elle a
été déposée par l'élu centriste qui
avait déjà évoqué de tels faits tout
comme deux autres femmes l'intéressé lui
dément la configuration politique de
sata semblait nous fait vivre une
situation presque inédite dans
l'histoire de la vème république avec
une représentation nationale qui est
appelé à prendre une place plus centrale
une nouvelle fois je conteste avec la
plus grande fermeté toute accusation de
tentative de viol ou d'agression
sexuelle je ne laisserai pas ces
accusations mensongères et scandaleuses
sans réponse ma détermination est totale
c'est pour ça qu'une plainte a tenté de
déposer cette religion a ce qu'il faut
votre client ne connaît pas laetitia
absolument pas l'émotion de yale brawn
pivi elle vient tout juste d'être élu à
l'un des postes les plus prestigieux de
la république
acclamé par les députés sous le regard
de ses parents
d'élèves à dire un faisceau de
présomptions quand même très fort est la
deuxième des choses c'est que vous avez
un devoir d'exemplarité lorsque vous
êtes ministre oui évidemment monsieur
abattre de démissionner ce pays qu
l'ambition jadis de livrer au monde un
message dont vous êtes aujourd'hui les
gars les hommes naissent et demeurent
libres et égaux
en me portant à votre présidence vous
donner aujourd'hui à ce message ont
porté nouvelles têtes ont dit voir ce
que ça va donner mais en tous les cas je
serais extrêmement vigilante sur
l'exercice de la démocratie c'est
difficile de prendre les attaques
médiatiques et les attaques
parlementaires les hôtels des
accusations de vivre les attaquants
l'électoral moi je ne commente pas les
affaires judiciaires lorsqu'il y en a je
les ai jamais fait je ferai jamais vous
savez les présidents de l'assemblée
c'est une fois à l'hôtel de lassay qui
donne la pleine mesure de même ou pas
ces agents de la sécurité de la mairie
de paris sont venus en aide à une drôle
de famille une canne et ses quatre
petits ont été escortés alors qu'il
traversait une route faut continuer à
rendre du pouvoir d'achat aux français
et donc il faut continuer à baisser la
pression fiscale sur les français on l'a
fait avec l'impôt sur le revenu la taxe
d'habitation hausse avec la redevance le
personnel de toutes les entreprises de
l'audiovisuel public se mobilise
aujourd'hui contre la suppression de la
redevance audiovisuelle c'était une
promesse de campagne d'emmanuel macron